[Música]
o lixo antigamente era mais rico jogadas
e muita coisa no lixo pelo chão
juntava as coisas reciclada e a gente
vendia com depósito maior já tinha um
negócio é a mas eu ganhava muito
dinheiro por dinheiro ela tinha
enterrado dinheiro quando eu tinha 9
anos
um belo dia cheguei à escola para minha
surpresa de um vendido o terreno já
tinham máquinas nem para o terreno e
junto com a limpeza foi o dinheiro que
pela primeira vez aí de uma idéia nós
fizemos um campo de futebol oficial
compramos a trave mandando a cultura de
fazer dois jogos de camisa e a gente
cobrava jogar e eu não tive problema eu
fiquei com dinheiro quem tem problema
meu pai salvar meu pai o que lady não
consigo arrumar um emprego de office boy
eu saí de casa cantando e voltava
cantando eu falei lá para ímola irão
esclarecer tudo e ajudá la finca 48
ordem da sua firma se daqui 10 anos a 20
anos você não puder comentou o prefeito
nem sócio pode ser eu peguei como eu a
convidei meu irmão trabalhar em um belo
dia de manhã e já tínhamos cinco
caminhões
os caminhões foram sair de manhã bateram
todos enfrentam tem uma determinação e
quando ele querem nada nada nada tira
ele falta de parceria com estrangeiros
resolvido embora nós ficamos na mão e
reinar estratégia quebrei pela quarta
vez só que dessa vez a conta maior do
dia
6 milhões
os negócios cresceram prosperaram eu vi
o geraldinho muito pobre pobre muito
rico perder tudo voltará a ficar rico 17
que a coisa mais interessante ele não
muda
[Música]
hoje eu tenho uma empresa de reciclagem
automotiva e cresce no mínimo 30% ao ano
se por acaso tiver uma pedra no caminho
ela vai ser integral porque eu vou
crescer de novo fazendo outra coisa
a minha filha costuma dizer que eu sou é
irritantemente feliz enquanto houver
vida humana e alimentação tem caminhão e
tem jr para poder dar manutenção foi bom
vou tentar trazer respeitar de troca
eles vêm aqui e falar com vocês de 18
minutos na história de eu tenho 58 anos
eu comecei a aprender como 8 como servir
a linha é e nunca tive um problema maior
que eu então eu contar a história de 50
anos que eu consigo sorrir a 50 anos
em 18 minutos eu vou tentar improvisar e
contar alguns trechos fez positivos cm
sem coitadismo cara brasileira é muito
bom que o que eu acho que atrapalha o
brasileiro e atrapalha o ser humano não
necessariamente o brasil mas as pessoas
as crenças naquilo que você acredita
eu sou um cara privilegiado eu nasci no
fundão lá onde não tinha médico não
tinha carteira na sic mulher aberta
fiquei que a maneira aberta com a
deficiência até os 8 anos de idade e eu
entendia que será positiva que
privilégio não podia chorar forte não
podia apanhar eu não conhecia não pensa
no negão mimado e aí isso foi positivo
uma mãe de são paulo buscar oportunidade
então ficamos sem nada lá a gente quando
você fica sem nada quando você fica sem
dinheiro quando você vai para o fundo do
poço
se você tiver fé e determinação se você
acreditar de verdade que você a
semelhança divina para disputar com o
tempo a sacanear ninguém se você
acreditar de verdade que você a
semelhança divina
você vai passar a acreditar em você
esses poderes essa essa positividade
essa energia está dentro de cada um de
nós nós somos iguais não tem esse papo
de que o pobre é mais difícil para o
negro é mais difícil ele não privilégio
e aí eu aprendi muito cedo com a minha
mãe
a gente era pequenininha uma mãe buscava
as coisas na feira pra comer essa de
ferro que sobrar vai lá e nós trazendo
para casa e lá eu aprendi que a mãe que
tinha prazer dividir com os vizinhos e
eu não tinha opção de falar com o
vizinho afogado que a mãe não deixava
democracia cubana
eu tinha a opção de concordar com a mãe
e aí eu dividia com o vizinho que a
gente trazia da feira e aprendi ali uma
coisa que todos nós podemos fazer é
independente da sua condição social em
vez de você lamentarem de vocês aqui
está difícil e você terceiriza achar que
alguém é culpado pela sua situação
o cara tem a gratidão independente da
sua condição social você pode ajudar o
próximo e nós ajudamos os próximos
naquela idade eu perdi a minha mãe eu
tinha menos de 18 anos a mãe foi embora
eu morava na favela mas eu já tinha
personalidade formado já tinha aprendido
que a minha mãe que todos nós podemos
aprender ea gente fica procurando ajuda
no mercado ajuda profissional cara não
tem ajuda melhor do que buscar os pais
da gente eu aprendi para trás
eu tive minha mãe não sabia ler não
sabia escrever mas ela tinha uma
sensibilidade foi a minha melhor ventura
a minha melhor coaching e ela dizia pra
mim o seguinte eu podia ela dizia que eu
era bonito é legal e ela ela dizia que
ia ser um vice e um homem que é ser um
cara do bem que esse trabalhador e eu
acreditei na minha mãe para você precisa
acreditar em alguém faça escolhas
acredita nos seus você tem que aprender
a fazer escolha logo cedo você pode
novamente não terceiriza não acho que
alguém é culpado pela sua situação a
culpa é sua você nasceu [ __ ] então por
que você nasceu
você nasceu a responsabilidade é sua e
depois que você nasceu só precisa de uma
oportunidade que a oportunidade que eu
precisava
minha mãe ensinou muito cedo pra mim ter
essa oportunidade e precisava de mais um
dia eu já nasci eu já tive o privilégio
de nascer eu precisava de mais um dia
ea mãe ensinava a gente o joelhinho
embaixo do tapete na cama que era
calçada com tijolo e ter gratidão
gratidão porque a luz que entrava pelo
barraco eu tinha que agradecer eu tive
mais um dia a luz divina e vontade cia e
nós vamos à luta
saía de casa oportunidade ter alguma
coisa pra fazer
a mãe foi embora arrumei um emprego com
oito anos de idade porque eu já tinha
aprendido que precisava ajudar o próximo
e eu podia ajudar o próximo próximo era
meu pai que é meu juízo que eu e eu fui
ajudar o papai arruma outra oportunidade
gente quando você tiver que olhar o
problema
olha pra cima o problema é seu quando
você olha pra ele encara o problema ele
fica menor que você não fuja do problema
você é um gerador nato de problema assim
que nasce o que significa que quando
você entende assumir a responsabilidade
que o problema é seu que a situação é
sua que o país é seu
os semelhantes são os seus brasileiros é
você então não fale mal de você mesmo
não fale mal do brasileiro não fale mal
da sua segunda mãe que seu país assuma
responsabilidade vai fazer eu aprendi
isso lá atrás eu fui fazer
arrumei uma oportunidade no aterro
sanitário foi catar latinha cara tá lá
tinha eu consegui constituir o meu 1º
negócio próprio porque com 89 ano e
previa no cnpj do cara lá 19 eu fui com
meu cnpj mental porque não tinha no
papel eu ganhei dinheiro de novo ganhar
dinheiro não é o problema
ganhar dinheiro é a coisa mais simples
do mundo quando você não tiver dinheiro
agradeça se o problema for só dinheiro é
única coisa um cubo bem é a única coisa
que têm valor que é insubstituível
dinheiro quais são os seus valores quais
são seus outros valores e outros valores
são família pessoas relacionamento
convivência ser feliz ter fé é a
espiritualidade tem credibilidade
a gente tem tantos valores que você vai
perceber quando você não tem dinheiro
falta um só da lista de valores e ele
fica na ponta da pirâmide da base são os
outros valores que dá sustentação para a
pirâmide
você precisa acreditar que você precisa
fazer escolhas você
precisa definir qual são seus valores
onde é que você tá aonde é que você quer
chegar à base dos valores e eu aprendi
esses valores e por conseqüência
trabalhando 12 horas por dia porque não
teve lá guiné por consequência ganhava
dinheiro então o dia não era um problema
quando eu lá eu quebrei meia dúzia de
vezes não é um problema eu nunca quebrei
a credibilidade nunca quebrei a moral eu
nunca tive vergonha de olhar para as
pessoas
gente eu venho aqui com um propósito
muito objetivo é de contagia um de vocês
a mudar o jeito de pensar e acreditar
que a solução está dentro de você quer
de dentro que você tira essa energia é
isso que faz a diferença pra você você
já nasceu com esse dom você já é a
semelhança divina não importa a religião
que você escolher a opção que você fez
se você acredita em você
se você tem que você vai conseguir eu
consegui eu não sou [ __ ] nenhuma mas
que ninguém
nós somos iguais se eu posso você também
pode nasci lá tive a opção de ir pra
seguir algum área negativa do crime na
favela eu fiz escolha eu escolhi o
carregamento tinha nas costas porque
aquele cara durava mais que o outro
eu queria viver então eu fiz a escolha e
aí eu continue fazendo escolha copia
universo tem tudo pronto você tem a
opção de fazer escolhas copiar aquilo
que está funcionando
você está num país fantástico que 80% é
positivo 80% dá certo 80% funciona full
time
ninguém pára de comer e de beber de
vestir de dormir então a economia
continua as pessoas falam de crise que
crise por nenhuma 80% do brasil dá certo
em 20% o que você vê na mídia deixa a
mídia isso você não vai poder mudar faça
parte dos 80 por cento que dá certo olha
pra cima assim tem um problema em algum
lugar que na área polícia acabou na hora
certa você participa se envolva se
comprometa faça mudanças passou escolhas
só depende de você quer aprender a
empreender você funcionário público tá
no cnpj de alguém empreender coisas de
dentro para fora vai fazer você vai
fazer entendendo que é pra você está
dentro do banheiro fazendo um quarto
fechado empreenda lá tem atitudes que é
o que você gostaria que você acredita
tem a melhor atitude quando ninguém está
vendo empresa de dentro pra fora não
importa o cnpj não é seu faça pra você
use o cnpj uma oportunidade e comece a
empreender onde você está é a melhor
maneira de começar você tem um negócio
tem uma idéia é ter um insight e preciso
investimento mais um emprego e começa
começa a produzir para diminuir a culpa
é do governo a culpa culpa é sua
não espere que alguém venha resolver o
seu problema o gerador de problema você
quem resolve o seu problema pra você e
eu fiz isso a vida inteira eu nunca tive
um problema maior que eu
a crise vai existir a vida inteira crise
é mudança crise é quando o dinheiro muda
de lugar o dinheiro vai mudar de lugar
vida inteira
se não tiver crise não tem evolução não
tem smartphone não tem tecnologia não
tem armazenamento na nuvem gente crise é
a necessidade que nós temos sim mudança
vai ter mudança vida inteira então para
decorrer da crise e ver onde é que você
se encaixa e comece agora quando agora é
o jeito de pensar
eu vim aqui com o objetivo de fazer com
que o apelante um de vocês
mude o jeito de pensar acredita em você
acredita que a capacidade de todos está
em nosso brasileiro é muito bom eu tive
esses dias de raiva para cada latinha
prepara em harvard legal
então eu fiquei alguns dias dando e
recebendo mentoria eu descobri uma coisa
e raiva que ninguém fala tudo vai para
lá de ovas nossa a ibyte nossa senhora a
ela não tem [ __ ] nenhuma
[Risadas]
desde lá tem tudo bonitinho e parece até
que o nosso prefeito lá passou lapidando
pichado
mas é o seguinte é só isso
o resto lá dentro tem pessoas como tem
nessa sala que quem está nessa sala que
está buscando conhecimento está buscando
conteúdo tá buscando evoluir e lá em
harvard aquelas pessoas estão buscando a
mesma coisa diferença daquelas salas com
a universidade nossa que o povo está
acontecendo dentro dessa fala aqui é
nenhuma a diferença é um detalhe
lá as pessoas acreditam nas pessoas
acredita que ele estava acima da média
lá as pessoas acredita que estão no país
ele tem orgulho da bandeira
lá as pessoas acreditam que os outros lá
fora também estão acreditando que eles
são o máximo
e essa diferença de energia esse jeito
de pensar diferente faz com que o mundo
todo se reverencia a raiva porque não a
nós porque nós somos iguais a capacidade
igual lá tinha um monte de brasileiros
tinha um cara lá que eu comecei a trocar
idéia com ele falava muito bem português
o cara da nasa ele vai pôr um satélite
até então ele só sabe fazer aquela porta
estava emperrada
o que significa que nós somos iguais
cada um desenvolve o seu grau de
inteligência o seu potencial
você pode ver que a maioria dos
bilionários não têm formação completa
isso significa que a capacidade da em
todos nós não tem abcd eu sou eu com 18
anos eu sou negro dá pra perceber uma
pele lisinha
então eu nasci lá eu nunca tive um
problema maior que eu perdi a minha mãe
e eu ainda morava na favela não foi um
problema
eu fui trabalhar na empresa que diziam
os casos de racismo e aí com essa eu não
entendo esse negócio lá eu cresci lá e
tive a oportunidade não trancar o porta
abre porta lá eu fui diretor lá eu
conseguir beneficiar investindo em
outras pessoas não conseguir crescer e
hoje as pessoas pergunta pra mim que
quando eu trabalhava no lixão eu comia
lá eu achava o queijo salame o sorvete
que havia vencido
as pessoas de tv e rufino e come aquilo
nossas e não tem trauma a equipe a uma
boa nova tem anticorpos para aquilo a
rafa cara é tudo de positivo é o ponto
de vista seu olhar pra cima pra baixo
então a idéia é essa gente eu posso você
pode todos nós podemos nós somos
brasileiros brasileiro é muito bom
brasileiro está adaptado à renascer das
cinzas e nem nascida nós estamos
está tudo dando certo parem de olhar
para a parte dos 10 ou 20 por cento que
não dá certo cabe a nós mudar o que não
dá certo tirar proveito e fazer parte do
dos 80% que dá certo assumir
responsabilidade depois fazer um
trabalho para mudar o que não está dando
certo só depende de nós
então qual é o objetivo quando haja um
de vocês eu sou fácil metas inatingíveis
então eu sou apaixonado por mim então eu
não sofro eu sou blindado
eu faço - atingíveis a ideia é vir aqui
comecei o que vocês contagiar um de
vocês acreditar em vocês acreditar no
país de vocês usar como coaching como
consultoria quem vocês quiserem desde
que a mãe o pai venha primeiro ouça o
seu coração acredita no seu filho
acredita em você acredita no seu
potencial
não fale mal da sua segunda mãe que é o
seu país tenha paixão tem amor pela sua
bandeira sair de casa de manhã com
paixão com determinação quem tem paixão
pelo que faz um cansa e você vai ver que
você pode atingir todos os seus
objetivos família relacionamento
profissional você pode tudo
é só questão de fazer escolhas nós somos
semelhança divina nós podemos tudo eu
posso tudo pensando um cara feliz porque
você não ama você nuno um sofre com a
crise que crise a gente existe e vai
continuar existindo porque as pessoas
ficam esperando a tal da crise passada
não vai passar
ela muda de lugar muda a situação muda
de cena
muda de colo ela está no seu colo passou
por colo do outro e ser uma situação de
evolução crise em vez de trocar por essa
palavra que assusta todo mundo busca por
evolução nós nós vamos evoluir se não
tiver isso não evoluiu faz uma
comparação muito simples que vão ver que
nós não temos um problema grave
pensa comigo morte parece ser mais
delicado que a crise ninguém quer perder
um ente querido nem tudo tem medo da
morte
então gente ninguém morrer mas não pôde
da mulher
agora se você consegue superar a morte
de um ente querido que você sabe que vai
morrer em poesia a gente acha que vai
durar todo mundo a vida inteira
se você consegue superar isso você
consegue reconhecer que precisa reciclar
e reciclagem sobre o rio é o meu negócio
nós vamos reciclar as pessoas precisam
reciclar as empresas também então se
você não evoluir natural que alguém
substitua você é isso que chamam de
crise o dinheiro muda de lugar isso vai
acontecer a vida inteira isso é vida ele
vai morrer vai acontecer a vida inteira
da natureza humana parede se assustar
com isto
pare de se achar que você é menor e que
você não vai conseguir
agora a gente a base de tudo isso lá na
infância para de falar do seu filho que
ele não pode parar de falar pra sua
menina ela é frágil ela vai ganhar menos
do que o menino que ela vai vai ser
bulli nada que ela vai incomodá lo à
escola
keller sexo frágil sexo frágil apoio à
mulher amada na gente pra [ __ ]
a área que falta pra mulher de ponto de
vista é a mesma coisa que falta para as
pessoas que se acham às vezes
discriminadas
a discriminação é uma frase é uma
insanidade uma fraqueza humana para se
preocupar com isso
ou é o o o deu um soco tem sempre alguém
discriminar alguém ou pelo sexo pela
religião pela raça pela cor
não tem jeito rocha é uma fraqueza
humana vai acontecer a vida inteira para
não terceirize não deixe ninguém ponha
isso na sua cabeça você diz acreditar em
você
o resto é conseqüência da insanidade
humana relaxa mundo que você pode
aceitar o que você não pode mudar você
pode mudar você você pode mudar você
começando a acreditar e tudo que eu falo
para vocês da experiência prática
eu vivo assim a vida inteira eu sou
feliz da vida inteira eu sou um
empreendedor empreendedor é um gerador
de oportunidades então você precisa
assumir responsabilidade entender que
você quer empreender então você vai ser
um gerador de oportunidades
eu tenho prazer em fazer isso eu não
faço mais que obrigação em contribuir
para essa mãe maravilhosa que é o nosso
país e sempre nos deu tudo de melhor
e hoje ainda me dá a oportunidade de
estar com pessoas maravilhosas como
vocês trocar energia de trocar boa ideia
e alinhar o aprendizado porque eu
aprendo quando eu falo para vocês ea
idéia era como eu disse pra você sabia
que contagiar um cão se eu conseguir
contagiar 2 sobre a meta
[Risadas]
e é isso
apaixonada pelo meu país sangue verde
acredito nas pessoas e eu acredito nas
pessoas até que prove o contário quando
o prove o contrário de uma segunda
chance e eu amo vocês do coração
beijo no coração peguei um gol cada
a brigada de gala gay
o mesmo